hi i'm natalie coughlin I'm here on the  Berkeley campus I'm in my suit I'm ready  to race I'm gonna challenge some random  people hi hi I'm here with BuzzFeed I  was wondering if you would race me in  the pool I was wondering if you guys  want to race me no thank you  uh these girls right here well you guys  race me Oh  internality Coughlin would you want to  race me  yeah do it alright let's do it I'm Jake  hi so let's just make this easy we'll  just go down and back so that's a 50 and  just so you know I've won 12 Olympic  medals  are you ready  you weren't warmed up it's okay good job  I thought Jake did quite well um I I  knew I would um but you know he hold his  own he held his own so terrific how come  she's not out of breath at all right now  you are left my water wings at home